[Musique]
bienvenue dans cette émission on va
parler de de l'entreprise avec justement
des chefs d'entreprise et de
l'entreprise confrontée à à la
croissance on dit souvent que une
entreprise qui ne veut pas disparaître
et et est condamné à la croissance mais
comment faire face à ce besoin de
croissance quelle stratégie choisir vers
quel type de croissance faut-il
s'orienter comment favoriser le
développement de l'entreprise quelles
peuvent être les partenaires de ce
développement autant de questions que
nous allons poser avec Virginie de
Neville bonjour bonjour vous êtes la
présidente et même l'heureuse président
parce que vous êtes en en croissance
assez
exponentielle de l'entreprise de léage
alors l'entreprise de c'est une
entreprise qui est consacrée à la
décoration év
Montiel l'exposition à la Signaléthique
hein oui exactement depuis 35 ans à 50
ans niiveline
absolument et et vous nous raconterez
parce que vous avez fait au fond une
période de de croissance un peu modeste
et puis après vous avez accéléré ça va
très intéressant de de nous raconter
Virginie FV bonjour bonjour euh vous
êtes la présidente de de StarTAC
l'heureuse aussi présidente il y a que
des heureux i donc chef d'entreprise
enfin on verra euh de STAC euh consacré
au au numérique c'est c'est je crois là
vous avez déjà créé trois entreprises
auparavant euh vous avez écé aussi un un
livre sur le i marketing stratégie
marketing c'est s stratégie marketing et
puis vous êtes la nouvelle présidente de
la CPME Eveline exactement voilà et donc
vous allez nous parler à la fois oui de
du besoin peut-être aussi de la
communication quand on est en croissance
des réseaux de importance des réseaux
euh Gill CIN bonjour bonjour vous êtes
le dirigeant fondateur d'ascondo conseil
alors ascondo je me suis dit c'est ask
and do c'est ça ah oui alors ça c'est
quand je vais me déployer en
Angleterre partout en Europe mais ça
vient de là ou pas pardon ça vient de là
ou pas non non non c'est latin en fait
c'est alors je saais pas le dire
exactement
àender c'estàdire c'est c'est passé
voilà c'est passé les différent étapes
et c'est accompagné les dirigeants pour
passer les différentes étapes de de de
croissance de leur entreprise d'accord
parce que esand cétait pas mal demander
puis fait hein ouais oua ouais en fait
j'avais pas pensé au départ et puis
c'est des copains qui m'ont dit oui ah
oui non mais ascandou ça serait pas mal
qu'est-ce que tu en pens et cetera donc
je suis resté sur l'idée dearts bien les
de les deux sont alors vous êtes
spécialiste de l'accompagnement et de la
transformation des des des PME ou donc
évidemment on va avoir besoin de de
votre éclairage et de vous conseil
Jean-Paul Mignard bonjour bonjour euh
vous êtes le fondateur d'axol axol c'est
une entreprise pour le innovante pour le
matériel d'accessibilité de mobilité
pour les personnes en situation de
handicap h euh et vous aussi alors vous
êtes euh enfin confrontter pas confronté
vous avez la volonté
d'accroître de votre entreprise oui
absolument accroître et développer
l'entreprise que j'ai créé il y a qui
est à trpe que j'ai créé il y a 13 ans
en démarrant seul à l'époque
et puis euh bien avec je dirais une une
opportunité d'intégration de d'un
fournisseur et donc de matériel
industriel pour fabriquer des rampes des
rampes d'accessivilité PMR euh et ben il
y a une grosse opportunité de
développement derrière et donc benah je
suis confronté à ces à trouver des
leviers pour pour accominer cette
croissance ouais lev et notamment euh
bah il faut il faut il y a toujours de
l'argent qu'il faut trouver et vous
allez pas aller euh vous allez pas aller
tirer la sonnette des banques vous nous
expliquerez pourquoi Absolum absolument
et puis Anna duen bonjour bonjour vous
êtes vous êtes le dirigeant de Anka
devveloppment ce qui est une entreprise
de restauration rapide he on peut dire
ça comme ça tout à fait ça dit Enka Enka
c'est un petit
villageurais pu deviner ça c'est un
petit village de Finlande où il fait bon
vivre donc où tout est tout est nature
oui c'est ça alors c'est entreprise de
restauration rapide mais de restauration
de bonne restauration rapide quoi
restauration LS et qui s'ad
principalement aux actifs aux gens qui
sont qui sont tous les midis sur leur
lieu de de travail bien que aujourd'hui
on est confronté au télétravail et on en
parlera peut-être tout à l'heure ce qui
crée un besoin de s'adapter aux
nouvelles habitudes de nos clients c'est
ça et alors en cas oui c'est c'est très
bien trouvé évidemment en cas le jeun
mot un en cas s absolument et alors et
vous bah vous êtes dans une période où
vous pensez à vendre votre entreprise et
oui euh bientôt bientôt sur le départ
départ de la retraite donc j'ai
travaillé ces derniers dernières années
avec le covid à revoir le fonctionnement
de mon entreprise puisqu'on est situé
spécialement en zone tertière
exclusivement j'allais même dire et
qu'aujourd'hui avec le télétravail il
faut s'adapter donc pour ça j'ai refait
une étude assez poussée du nouveau
concept on a gardé l'ADN mais on a
changé autour et on va être en zone
plus de fort passage zone centrreeville
centrecô vous êtes où euh on est sur la
région parisienne grenobble et Marseille
et on peut être dans toutes les grandes
villes de France sans problème très bien
alors on va aborder plusieurs plusieurs
question qui qui se pose bah avec vous
comment faire face justement à à la
croissance avec quel partenaire on peut
est-ce qu'il faut des partenairire
comment on les trouveré mais peut-être
on va d'abord poser une question Deah
qu'est-ce que c'est la croissance dans
une entreprise il y a la croissance
interne et la croissance externe c'est
le premier chapitre de cette
[Musique]
émission alors euh justement j CIN
peut-être avec vous peut-être un mot
qu'est-ce que c'est on dit la croissance
d'une entreprise alors évidemment c'est
TR d'avoir plus de clients
d'avoir plus de chiffres d'affaires mais
c'est pas que ça la croissance en fait
ça ça permet de péréniser l'entreprise
c'est vraiment un objectif de tout
entrepreneur quand il il crée son
entreprise il veut la péréniser euh et
donc ça c'est en fait il y a il y a six
levier de croissance qu'on peut
identifier aujourd'hui il y a il y a la
croissance interne on fait avec ce qu'on
a on développe plus on va chercher plus
de clients on va communiquer plus mais
avec les ressources dont on dispose
l'entreprise c'estd qu'on on on n'engage
pas forcément plus de salariés non on
essaie de faire mieux aveon voilà donc
c'est ça la croissance interne ou ouais
donc il y a toujours des il y a toujours
des leviers à un moment donné toujours
des choses qu'on peut faire de façon
différente euh alors on peut excusez-moi
en fait on peut aussi aller chercher euh
des des moyens supplémentaires pour
aller pour aller pour embaucher pour
acheter des des machines par exemple euh
mais on va rester dans un cadre vraiment
interne à l'entreprise ça après le
deuxième levier ça va être la croissance
externe donc on va aller chercher une
entreprise euh là il faut vraiment se
méfier euh de de de de la vision qu'on
peut avoir en fait de l'entreprise de la
vision stratégique pour aller vraiment
chercher une entreprise qui soit
complémentaire donc on peut faire de
l'intégration àont ou de l'intégration
aval on peut aller dans une autre zone
géographique on peut aller chercher
enfin carrément aller prendre différent
voilà ou après on peut faire aussi de de
trè levier c'est l'esmage stratégique on
a un actif latant dans l'entreprise
quelque chose qu'on a pas qu'on pousse
pas suffisamment et donc on va on va
aller le pousser de façon plus forte euh
pour aller euh conquérir de nouveaux par
exemple de nouveaux marchés ou de
nouveaux clients euh le 4e ça va être la
croissance en réseau c'est la franchise
ou la ou la licence B ça c'est assez
classique le 5e ça va être la
diversification donc on va avoir de la
diversification soft ou de la
diversification hard donc selon oui
selon là où on met le curseur là où on
conna le terrain où on conna pas ah oui
euh la diversification hard ça va être
euh je vais être sur un euh sur un
marché que je ne connais pas avec des
produits que je ne connais pas enfin que
j'ai pas encore développé pardon je je
vais les connaître mais je les ai pas
encore développé et puis le dernier
c'est euh
euh c'est bah bah
l'internationalisation d'accord voilà
oui oui ça c'est donc les si leviers si
levier euh vous vous vous vous
reconnaissez dans on va parler après de
de votre expérience spécifique mais dans
dans ce que vient de dire Gilles
oui oui absolument sachant que
évidemment ce n'est pas un levier unique
mais on peut avoir un mix de de
l'ensemble de ces leviers
effectivement à activver voilà et une
ville c'est vrai que vous avez une
croissance interne assez douce pendant
pendant quelques années hein oui à
peaufiner je dirais le business model à
rendre belle la mariée pour qu'elle
puisse justement un jour exploser éclore
et là on est arrivé au-delà de ça en
fait on voit bien que le le l'entreprise
est prête à absolument prête sur tous
les plans à à se développer là à croître
d'une manière beaucoup plus
asymptotique alors on va revenir
peut-être à la première croissance qui
est la croissance interne euh vous dites
qu'il y a
plusieurs Levi plus plusieurs étapes
plusieurs d'abord la création de valeur
évidemment après utilisation
enfin trois grands changements de
paradigme vous parlez du digital et ça
ça va intéresser Virginie évidemment la
décarbonation ça c'est vrai que c'est
très important et je pense que alors ça
c'est une petite parenthèse mais les les
les petites et moyennes entreprises que
vous présentez je crois il me semble
qu'elles font un effort sur sur le les
les sur les les problèmes que pose le
changement climatique encore plus fort
que les grandes entre est-ce que je me
trompe bah nous on est déjà très en
avance depuis 15 ans avec un ISO 14001
qui est bien mû chez nous et qui nous a
permis d'accéder très facilement au RSE
du coup avec des compléments de de piste
d'amélioration et on a c'estz facilement
récupérer médaille d'or mais ça nous a
aussi permis d'accéder à des tas de
marchés qu'on aurait jamais eu
absolument ouais euh et donc digital
décarbonation et managérial hein c'est
ça les les trois et ça en fait c'est euh
c'est vraiment des opportunités pour les
entreprises pour de créer de la valeur
de façon différente à ce queon faisait
auparavant vous parliez la première
question au début c'était de parler de
de croissance aujourd'hui une entreprise
elle est obligée de faire de la
croissance faire du surplace ça devient
très dangereux euh ça ça l'était il y a
10 ans il y a 15 ans aujourd'hui ça l'
est encore plus et par exemple de
d'appréhender le sujet de sur le digital
ou d'appréhender le sujet sur la
décarbonation ça force l'entreprise à se
poser des questions de façon différente
à regarder ce qui peut exister sur le
sur le marché sur la concurrence et donc
de changer son business mod vous parlez
de business model vraiment changer son
business model euh de de de façon à
créer encore plus de valeur et la créer
de la valeur c'est quoi bah c'est
augmenter la productivité pour plus de
valeur pour l'entreprise pour le le pour
les actionnaires et puis pour le les
dirigeant pour euh et pour le et pour
les salariés également et et tout ça ça
permet en fait de plus vous créez de la
valeur plus vous faites de la
rentabilité plus vous augmentez vos
fonds propres et du coup vous pouvez
alimenter en fait une et solidifier
votre votre entreprise absolument
Virginie là-dessus enfin tu parles g
parle de Digital c'est vrai que c'est
important au moment de la croissance
d'abord de le faire savoir et et de et
de de d'incarner aussi l'entreprise
qu'on dirige et je crois qu'il a
différents stades j'entends souvent
certains dire me dire on a pas besoin de
ça on vend et ça fonctionne en fait la
Marie n'est jamais aussi belle que quand
elle a besoin de rien et c'est vra je je
je préconnis souvent aux gens de de
commencer très très vite à travailler
leur personnal branding sur les réseaux
sociaux justement au moment où on a
besoin de rien puisque effectivement on
est beaucoup plus attirant que lorsqu'on
est en demande et je pense qu'en fait ça
répond à tellement d'objectifs
développer son chiffre d'affaires
rassurer ses clients fidéliser trouver
des partenaires trouver des
investisseurs moi j'avoue ça fait
maintenant
16 ans que je suis dans je suis dans
l'entrepreneuriat et je crois que sans
LinkedIn ça aurait été plus compliqué
exactement et ça ouvre des portes je
rejoins Gill aussi sur sur cette façon
aussi d'avoir de percevoir la stratégie
aujourd'hui on est plutôt dans une phase
de coréation de finalement de de
produits avec nos clients on voit plein
d'entreprises qui ont pivoté parce que à
la demande des clients finalement c'est
plus seulement un un un ressenti ou une
volonté interne c'est aussi répondre à à
une demande qui se construit avec les
retours en ligne et c'est vrai que c'est
important d'être présent sur ces
plateformes et de pas négliger cet
aspect-l pas négliger c'est vrai oui que
c'est c'est aussi une façon oui de de
c'est plus facile aujourd'hui aussi de
faire connaître une entreprise que ça ne
l'était il y a il y a probablement 10 ou
15 ans oui et puis il y a plusieurs
paramètres qu'il faut prendre en compte
dans le fait vous disiez sur la partie
incarnation oui on doit incarner notre
entreprise parce que il y a 20 ans
c'était un gros logo des un gros
bâtiment on Savit même pas qui était à
la tête de l'entreprise voà aujourd'hui
on achète un
exactement et aujourd'hui on achète un
produit parce qu'on achète les valeurs
du coup du patron de l'équipe et c'est
important que ces valeurs soit
communiqué on veut aussi l'humanisation
on veut une relation de proximité
exister face face à l'entreprise et et
je pense que il y a voilà les choses ont
bien changé il faut prendre en compte ce
paramètre je
min vous vous utilisez les réseaux
sociaux les ah de plus en plus de plus
en plus et et je dirais de depuis depuis
maintenant un an et demi ou 2 ans et je
dirais que les les résultats sont
absolument effectivement étonnants par
rapport à ça étonnant en terme de je
dirais de Retour d'échange de de de
personnes qui qui finalement qui
interréagissent sur des sur des posts
qui sont donné qu'on attendait pas du
tout euh et puis de je dirais de de
création directe de contact également
avec des utilisateurs par exemple qui
sont la plupart du temps filtrés par des
revendeurs des distributeurs et auxquels
on n pas on n' pas accès et pas que
quantitativement mais également
qualitativement et en échange sur sur
les produits les services qu'on est à
même d'apporter ce qui nous permet
d'ajuster éventuellement oui là de
cealer beaucoup plus directement par
rapport à ça oué Deville bah nous on a
mis en place des routines pour que cette
communication soit régulière puisque la
régularité est incontournable ou oui oui
il faut il faut pas le faire de temps en
temps et puis pas le faire pendant trop
Mo donc la routine a permis ça en effet
ça ça crée une dynamique d'entreprise
qui est qui est aussi une signature de
les les bien sr voilà à partir du moment
où il y a une dynamique on fait plus on
fait plus confiance à des gens qui sont
dans le Move et qui sont dynamiques pu
des gens qu'on ne sait pas ce qu'ils
font ouais al duc puisque vous êtes dans
dans cette période de V évidemment
est-ce que ah bah les réseaux sociaux
c'est absolument incontournable et je
dirais même qu'avant il suffisait
d'avoir un beau bâtiment un logo euh
pour un point de vente une superbe
venture dans un emplacement numéro 1
l'emplacement l'emplacement
l'emplacement aujourd'hui aujourd'hui
les gens passent devant chez vous si
vous faites pas de communication il vous
voi pas il continue et ils vous ont pas
vu donc il faut absolument en faire
parce que la concurrence elle bah est
active làdessus surtout on a vu beaucoup
de de jeunes issus des écoles de
commerce arrivé avec
toutes en remettant en plat les codes du
commerce et ils se sont emparés bien sûr
des réseaux sociaux il y a des succès
story avec avec la communication
notamment donc il faut être jeune pour
pour bien aller à fond dans cette
communication et et c'est devenu
vraiment fondamental oui vir quand quand
les des entreprises viennent vous voir à
STAC enfin justement pour pour
travailler la la façon dont ils vont
communiquer sur les réseaux sociaux ils
le font en amont c'està dire avant
d'avoir besoin justement comme vous
disiez de de communiquer où est-ce
qu'ils le font au moment justement où
ils sont en pare de de croissance et ils
ont besoin de de cette communication là
en fait il a différence il y a
différents cas il y a différents cas
vous conseillerez de le faire plutôt en
amont quoi c'est ça moi je dis le plusôt
possible et je rejoins effectivement
Virginie sur la régularité puisque il
s'agit pas de se dire je crée un compte
et j'attends que que les choses se
fassent il faut effectivement ce qu'on
dit s'ancrer dans le quotidien des gens
c'est que aujourd'hui on a déjà parler
sur ce plateau mais les gens consomment
se lèvent avec leur téléphone se
couchent avec leur téléphone et font
beaucoup de choses avec leur téléphone
oui on va pas dire si c'est bien ou
c'est mal ve mais c'est jugera pas mais
en tout cas ce qui est sûr c'est que on
peut créer un lien très fort de
proximité et et et du coup des routines
des habitudes et et s'inscrire un peu
dans leur vie pour raconter aussi bah
des histoires parce que c'est bien aussi
de vouloir venter les mérites de son
produit et c'est très bien de vouloir le
valoriser mais aujourd'hui les discours
commerciaux ont leur limite ce qu'on
attend finalement ce qu'attend de
l'audience en la la les gens sur les
réseaux sociaux c'est qu'on les emmène
dans des univers qu'on leur partage du
lien des émotions un peu un peu de en
tout cas de choses qui leur donne envie
de lire faut aller plus loin que la
simple proposition du produit quoi
exactement on peut plus se permettre
juste de matraquer effectivement avec
des promos en disant voilà et je suis le
meilleur et dire qu'on est le meilleur
ça n'a pas le même impact que raconter
une histoire ou son client dit quelque
chose qui qui qui app puiss C en tout
cas ce ce propos quoi Gill CIN euh vous
parlez de nouveau aussi business mode et
et alors ça va peut-être
intéresser notre ami an duucade mais
vous dit maintenant on peut vendre
l'usage et non la possession alors
est-ce que vous pouvez expliquer ça ou
oui alors ça c'est un sujet que j'aime
beaucoup euh qui est un peu peut-être
encore parfois théorique sur en B2B
moins moins en B2C le l'usage plus que
la possession c'est par exemple euh vous
vous avez l'usage de votre voiture mais
vous n'avez pas la possession de votre
voiture d'AC comprend donc ça on
comprend bien euh c'est un phénomène qui
commence à se développer vers vers
l'industrie euh et qui peut permettre
aussi demain par exemple de de dire bon
bah un client ne va pas forcément
posséder la machine mais va va en avoir
l'usage ma même être va payer pour du
résultat
euh et donc il n'aura pas il n'aura pas
la machine en fait il va pas
besinvestir dans la machine oui il va il
va payer l'usage donc ça c'est un
nouveau business model je trouve qui est
extrêmement intéressant euh parce que
d'abord ça va coûter moins cher aux
entreprises on va pouvoir démultiplier
les les machines par exemple plusieurs
plusieurs entreprises pourront utiliser
plusieurs machines différentes en la
même machine à des moments qui vont être
différents euh il y a un côté aussi euh
euh de moindre utilisation des matières
premières à un moment donné puisqu'on va
moins oui bien sûr c'est pas la peine
d'immobiliser voilà on va pouvoir
recycler aussi ces machines là donc bon
c'est un business model aujourd'hui qui
est on le voit bien sur sur les voitures
on le voit bien par exemple sur sur les
sur la vidéo sur la musique et cetera
c'est un business model qui marche très
très bien on voit un petit peu moins sur
l'industrie il y a force je pense qu'il
y a beaucoup de potentiel là-dessus on
travaille on a fait un groupe de travail
avec la CCI sur ce sujet et c'est
vraiment oui j'ai j'ai oublié de de
préciser que c'estêtes membre de la la
Chambre de commerce et industrie des
ivelines précis prés monsieur kou voilà
Guillaume kerou ouais tout à fait euh et
donc c'est vraiment enfin je pense que à
terme ça va être relativement moteur il
y a encore quelques freins qui vont qui
sont aujourd'hui les banques ne suivent
pas forcément puisque elles aiment bien
investir contre une machine pas
forcément contre un service donc ça
c'est toujours un petit peu le li la
limite effectivement et puis au niveau
des datas
puisque le fait d'avoir des machines de
ce type là va permettre de partager des
datas d'enrichir et bon là on a quelques
contraintes quand même rgpd qui sont qui
sont assez fort assz fort mais vous Dirz
oui que c'est une nouvelle étape là
qu'on est en train de vivre qui va
peut-être changer un peu enfin certains
visages en tout cas de l'industrie quoi
B moi personnellement j'aimerais bien
j'ai un côté assez optimiste en général
je vois souvent le vert à moitié plein
pour pas que je me trompe donc plutôt
plein c'est plein ou mais les banquiers
ouais ça va être surtout les banquiers
qui vont être à convaincre mais je pense
que ça va finir
par se faire puisque aujourd'hui on va
quand même vers une une une une société
avec moins de matières premières on
faudra faire attention aussi à à la à
l'utilisation en fait des différentes
matières premières donc je pense que ça
va ça va dans le bon sens alors dernier
point puis après on va aborder les les
cas pratiques si je peux dire euh mais
ça ça va intéresser à parler de la de la
justement de la vente de l'entreprise et
et vous dites il faut permettre au
dirigeants de se rendre inutile ah oui
alors ça c'est aussi c'est oui c'est
intéressant parce que c'est vrai que la
la coprésence de celui qui vend et de
ceux qui ont acheté souvent ça marche
pas forcément très bien alors il y a ça
effectivement et donc la période de
recouvrement des fois il faut il faut
pas forcément qu'elle soit trop longue
hein on parle de 6 mois mais peut-être
des fois il faut même réduire encore à à
moins de 6 mois d'accord et puis euh
vous vous achetez une entreprise
admettons de de 10 12 personnes mais
dans cette entreprise là le patron il
est omniprésent il fait tout de la cave
auier on en connaît plein des
entreprises comme ça oui et bien vous
achetez l'entreprise l'ancien patron
s'en va que devient l'entreprise c'est
ça la difficulté c'est aujourd'hui il y
a une perte de valeur forte quand le
dirigeant s'en va et donc quand une
entreprise veut enfin un dirigeant veut
vendre son entreprise il faut qu'il
réfléchisse quelques années avant quand
même pour pouvoir anticiper les process
et pour qu'il soit inutile voilà oui
c'est intéressant vous avez pensé à ça
bien s j'avais la petite histoire
normalement vendu mon entreprise avant
le covid et le covid a stoppé tous
les vousééch à tout ça ça tout remis en
question mais
exactement surtout dans les petites
entreprise comme la mienne entreprise
familiale le chef d'entreprise il fait
50% des chos si ce n'est plus en tout
cas il est il est au au départ de la
stratégie de de l'entreprise et et la
vente de l'entreprise où elle se fait
avec tout un staff et à ce moment-là
c'est pas le même prix non plus c'est
pas la même entreprise non plus mais
pour les petites entreprises ça assez
difficile mais d'un autre côté ça peut
être facile puisque n'importe quel chef
d'entreprise peut s'intégrer directement
à la reprise et puis mettre sa patte
alors c'est sûr que deux chefs
d'entreprise dans le cadre
c'est pas possible he il faut il faut
qu'il y en ait un qui s'en aille vite
sinon ça marche pas alors on va on va
justement parler ben de de de exemples
de de de léage et et
d'axol deux entreprises qui voilà
confronté au problème de la croissance
donc c'est ça c'est deuxème partie cette
émission deux entreprises face à la
[Musique]
croissance alors on va commencer avec
avec vous ville par parler de l'age
entre vous disiez il y a 35 ans à peu
près c'est ça ah oui un peu plus de 35
ans 89 89 vous avez toujours installé
ici à à Montin bronneux puis à
effectivement 50 an d'Eline donc à
aencour voilà et en 2003 on a déménagé
pour avoir des locaux plus grands alors
je rappelle vous êtes spécialisé dans la
décoration événementiel le stand
l'exposition La signalytique hein c'est
ça exaement donc un spectre large alors
vous dites bah au fond pendant pendant
pendant assez longtemps enfin depuis 35
ans on a opté pour une progression
maîtrisée constante et régulière he
c'est ça oui avec un objectif de créer
un bel outil du coup à la je dirais au
niveau de mes de mes de mes moyens de ma
mesure je voulais rester vraiment en
maîtrise de l'outil donc c'est la raison
pour laquelle je suis restée seul dans
au commande de l'entreprise donc c'est
la raison pour laquelle j'ai j'ai choisi
une une croissance douce euh
voilà aujourd'hui effectivement on
parlait de de de rendre le chef
d'entreprise je dirais de de d'oublier
d'être l'homme clé donc j'ai beaucoup
travaillé là-dessus oui et juste c'estd
que voilà alors il y a cette croissance
pendant une traine d'ÉE jusqu'en 2019 à
peu près hein et à partir de 2019 vous
mettez l'accélérateur quoi c'est ça oui
alors à partir de 2019 c'est ça donc il
s'est pendant le covid j'ai donc décidé
de oui le covid he c'est important nous
on a quand même réussi à à convertir nos
produits en produit covid pour continuer
à produire et l'outil a continué à
fonctionner un peu en sommeil certes
mais on n pas du tout de gros problèmes
et et c'est à ce moment-là que j'ai
décidé de de moi libérer l'entreprise
libérer en tant que chef d'entreprise de
libérer de vous-même c'est ça ou donc
libérer l'entreprise ça veut pas dire
que j'abandonne le bateau bien au
contraire ça veut dire que je travaille
sur l'important et je ne travaille plus
sur l'opérationnel donc je travaille
plus sur l'urgence donc vous avez
transmis un certain nombre de prérogativ
enfin de responsabilité à des à des
salariés ex c'est ça donc j'ai j'ai fait
formmer j'ai formé j'ai on a fait du
coaching individuel pour monter des gens
en compéten et le fait de de me mettre
en recul en métaposition finalement de
mon entreprise ça a eu plusieurs effets
vertueux l'un de responsabiliser les les
les collaborateurs qui se sont révélés
complètement et et de moi de observer
mon entreprise pour aller mettre
l'accent sur des travaux beaucoup plus
stratégiques ou av vu un peu de
l'extérieur quoi presque c'est ça et ça
ça ça fonctionnait facilement parce que
euh c'est c'est c'est je trouve que le
votre réussite est magnifique le
discours vous avez est tout à fait
passionnant mais parfois
euh est-ce que on tombe pas sur des
salariés qui se retrouvent un peu perdu
quand ils ont pas quelqu'un qui les qui
les dirige comme il les dirigea avant ce
n'est pas abandonner le bateau ça veut
dire je les ai accompagné ça s fait
voilà il faut il faut trouver le le bon
et vous le disiez il faut anticiper tout
ça quand on on veut obtenir un un
résultat parfois 4 4 ans pour le murir 5
ans pour le M rir donc moi c'est ce que
j'ai fait je vraiment j'ai pris de
l'élan et et cette passation s'est fait
au fil de l'eau après un moment donné
j'ai coupé simplement le fait que je
fais plus de devis je je gère plus les
clients en direct et ça je l'ai j'ai pu
prendre cette décision à partir du
moment où j'ai compris que la personne
que j'avais choisi était apte à le faire
voilà et à partir de là les clients non
disent pas mais oui madame de
nville non en fait très rapidement enfin
je pense que les cimetières sont plein
de gens
irremplaçables c'est vrai mais c'est
mais c'est c'est une révolution he pour
pour une entreprise de faire ce que vous
avez fait je trouve enfin mais j'ai été
très étonné de voir les résultats enfin
j'attendais pas du tout des résult
appareil donc ça ça a vraiment donné du
de la croissance à l'entreprise alors
progresser aussi dans la certification
vous parliez tout à l'heure d'une
médaille d'or que que vous avez obtenu
qui la médaille d'or est covadice c'est
ça oui euh donc bon certification enfin
maximal et
puis et puis vous avez consu aussi de
nouveaux produits oui alors
effectivement tous les ans je développe
des produits maison qui répondent à une
certaine demande e qu'on pourrait s pas
forcément s'imaginer au départ et on
s'aperçoit que bien modélisé bien
communiqué on s'aperçoit que la la la on
va créer la la la demande et ces
produits stratégiques
différenci l'entreprise et surtout ouvre
à de nouveaux clients parce qu'en fait
c'est des gens qu'on a capté par ce B là
qu'on aurait pas forcément capté avec
l'offre habituelle et donc en effet
voilà avec des dépôts de marques et
despôts de modèles
pour pour consolider le l'appartenance
du produit à l'entreprise et les
résultats sont Fab alors depuis que vous
occupez plus de chez vous vous avez s
d'affire progressé de 65 % mais oui mais
en fait j'en suis fierre parce que c'est
voilà la réussi ça à faire ce passage en
douceur quand même et qui fait que oui
l'entreprise a plutôt c'est plutôt a
plutôt cru comme on dit ah oui on est on
est on a effectivement alors le
l'objectif après ça a été conserver les
marges parce que l'objectif c'est pas de
faire du chiffre mais c'est quand même
de conserver la marge et en fait j'ai
été surprise de voir que non seulement
le chiffre augmenta mais la marge aussi
donc là j'ai dit c'est de la
drogue c'est pas voilà mais non on a je
pense que c'est une très très bonne
méthode de responsabiliser les les
personnes avec qui on travaille pour
pour le moins qu'ils aient je veux dire
les compétences et bien choisir s c la
motivation l'envie c'est pour ça qu'il
faut du temps pour pour valider donc
voilà est-ce que alors il a eu la la
crise de la covid enfin qui était un
élément peut-être moteur involontaire
puisque ça enfin ça venait de
l'extérieur mais est-ce qu'il y a un
moment où on peut se dire vous avez fait
justement cette période de croissance
régulière comm et et est-ce que vous
avez évidemment encore une fois il y a
la crise du covid mais est-ce que vous
avez choisi le moment où vous êtes dit
voilà on va passer à un autre stade un
autre développement alors juste après le
covid quand j'ai vu que les les clients
justement se réancr sur ma nouvelle
équipe sur mon
équipe je me suis dit là là c'est j'ai
une forte de frappe bien supérieure et
maintenant il faut y aller donc c'est là
que j'ai j'ai regardé tous les les
aspects de l'entreprise toutes les
briques à consolider
RSE et bien d'autres les produits le
matériel le 5S l'ergonomie et cetera et
euh et le le rgpd enfin tout ce qui fait
qu'une entreprise est est bien fichue en
fait hein et fonctionne bien et
euh chantier après chantier j'appelle ça
des chantiers hein euh on a revu la
copie sur tous ces aspects et euh et ça
ça était après le covid une fois libéré
du je dirais du suspense que nous
procurer ce covid pas savoir où on
allait aller et là direct derrière quand
j'ai vu comment ça repartait j'ai dit ça
est ça y est quoi ouais ça y est alors
là augmentation du chiffre d'affair de
la mche vous l'avez dit
mais il y a quand même est-ce qu'il y a
des risques quand même est-ce que vous
dites il y a quand même des risques qui
sont liés à la croissance d'une
entreprise dans mon cas les risques
étaient toujours maîtrisés finalement
puisque c'est de la croissance interne
on n'est pas parti sur des choses en
dehors de notre zone de confort
peut-être un peu augmenter de temps en
temps un peu la sous-traitance pour
absorber l'excès de de prod de
production prendre quelques petits
locaux supplémentaires mais rien
qui qui finalement met en danger l're et
surtout l'entreprise avait les moyens de
ça parce que on a on a capitalisé
suffisamment pour être pour prétendre à
cette croissance donc on a on on avait
les moyens justement de de bah de de se
tester dans ce nouveau business model
mais voilà un un mot de parce que vous
vous l'utilisez probablement mais
peut-être vous aussi je voudrais bien
avoir votre sentiment là-dessus sur
l'intelligence
artificielle vous l'utilisez c'est de
l'ge
évidemment c'est c'est considéré alors
d'abord vous comment vous la considérez
et puis et puis peut-être les les gens
qui travaill dans dans les entreprises
comment comment il la voitent venir
comment il voit venir son importance et
peut-être ça moi je dis que c'est un
outil de plus h à utiliser je
dirais avec précaution parce que c'est
tellement magique et je pense que dans
la vie r en est magique et qu'il y a
toujours le rever le revers de la
médaille l'intelligence artificielle
apporte beaucoup de facilité dans la
rédaction dans facilité de faire des
images des choses comme ça mais à côté
de ça ça ça crée aussi des effets
secondaires
ou qui pourrait venir demain et on sait
peut-être même pas encore lesquels donc
pour moi c'est un outil formidable au
jour d'aujourd'hui et à voir ce qui va
se passer demain en fait je suis quand
même moi dans l'interrog parce
qu'aujourd'hui je c'est super mais
justement il va y avoir des effets
secondaires voilà souv les spéci il faut
gouverner l'intelligence artificielle et
pas se faire gouverner par elle ENF
c'est ça puis la propriété
intellectuelle à qui appartient C cette
production de contenu quoi vous
l'utilisez pour les pour
les pour la gestion du personnel aussi à
nous pas encore pas encore parce que ça
se fait de plus
plusou oui oui ça maintenant ça rentre
vraiment ça ça rentre dans l'entreprise
tous les ét d'ailleurs à tous les étages
et puis les logiciels utilisent oui nous
on n'est pas encore encore
làdessus làdessus sur l'utilisation de
l'intelligence artificielle notamment
dans
lah je sais pas mais en tout cas d'un
point de vue global c'est vrai que comme
vous disiez ça ça ça infuse de plus en
plus dans les entreprises aujourd'hui
c'est considéré comme un outil
effectivement va falloir quand même
surveiller l'évolution de de ça parce
que moi je vois par exemple pour pour
pour des
codeurs des informaticiens ils vont
utiliser l'intelligence artificiel pour
aider dans les dans le codage demain
jusqu'où ça va aller c'estd il y a plein
de métiers comme ça qui peuvent être
quand même en suspend ça va tellement
vite il y a de il y a quoi ça ça 1 an et
3 mois quoi à peu près donc on en
parlait pas absolument ouais donc c'est
c'est assez c'est assez pH al moi je
trouve comme comme accélérateur
euh j'espère que ça va rester comme un
outil
euh qui va aideriseon peut utiliser
qu'on peut maîtriser quoi mais ouais
voilà c'est ça après il faudra
surveiller la maîtrise quand
[Musique]
même dans la communication dans les
réseaux sociaux et parce que ça enfin ça
pourrait remplacer av vantageusement un
community manager non lia alors ce qui
est sûr c'est que ça solutionne pas mal
de de on peut l'utiliser en tout cas je
dis pas que ça
c'est pas un tabou que de dire que
aujourd'hui une génération qui arrive
avec des fautes d'orthographe et que
c'est vrai utiliser ne
seraitjà DISP exement que ne serait-ce
que corriger ses postes sur c'est plutôt
pas mal ensuite effectivement ça fait
gagner un temps fou par contre il faut
quand même bien maîtriser l'art des
promptes ou évidemment parce que sinon
ça peut faire des choses assez
superficielles oui comme ça c'est assez
banal généralement c'est vous disiez il
fautut s'impliquer dans cette dans cette
communication à travers les réseaux
sociaux enfin faut fautut avoir un peu
de chair quoi et c'est vrai que si s'il
y a que l'intelligence artificielle elle
est un peu et puis et puis il y a des
notions à distinguer parce que lia
existe depuis des années c'est parce
qu'elle est portée au public et qu'elle
est elle permet l'accessibilité au grand
public en revanche faut pas confondre l'
a et l'automatisation c'estd que
certains pensent qu' un B sur un sur un
site à un chat quoi c'est un c'est de
l'IA bon l'a c'est quand même une
intelligence qui apprend c'est quand
même bien plus sophistiqué oui c'est ça
c'est pas juste ça reproduit pas juste
hein exactement mais ce qui est
intéressant en revanche c'est que alors
nous on intervient beaucoup en intra
dans nos formation on a beaucoup
d'entreprises qui nous sollicitent pour
des problématiques très précises euh et
pour travailler aussi effectivement au
sein de la stratégie il y a aussi des
agences qui commencent à l'utiliser pour
pour trouver des punchlines pour il y a
vraiment quand on pousse l'outil et
qu'on le connecte à plusieurs autres
outils c'est plutôt intéressant et donc
il y a plein de possibilités donc lia ça
veut tout dire et rien dire on l'utilise
chacun à notre niveau euh ce qui est sûr
c'est que pour l'instant en première en
première step en tout cas l'utiliser
pour faire ses post LinkedIn bah c'est
vrai qu'au lieu de passer euh 3h par
mois si on peut passer une heure ça peut
libérer un peu de temps et c'est ça peut
être intéressant en tout cas ouis euh
Jean-Paul minignard on va parler d'axol
oui qui est aussi entreprise en en en
développement alors euh vous disiez vous
l'avez créé il y a il y a 13 ans 13 ans
ou de l'industrie hein euh euh oui de
l'industrie agroalimentaire absolument
rien à voir rien rien rien à voir euh
donc c'est une c'est une entreprise qui
fabrique et distribue des solutions
d'accessibilité de mobilité pour les
particuliers pour les collectivités et
pour les entreprises hein euh et
oui faites aussi la location de de de
matériel de mobilité
euh vous avez vous êtes combien de
salariés aujourd'hui 17 salariés
aujourd'hui salentreise voilà vous êtes
à trappe et alors vous avez décidé la
c'est une c'est une décision euh forte
de tripler euh votre chiffre d'affaires
c'est ça c'est l'objectif ouais dans les
dans les quatre dans qu 5 ans à venir de
de de tripl chiff d'affaires alors là
c'est euh c'est sur une je dirais c'est
partie de croissance effectivement de
croissance interne et de développement
deactivité il se trouve que euh nous
avons identifié euh dans le cas de nos
activités de de fourniture de de rampes
d'accès pour les personnes handicapées
et personnes âgées euh qu'un certain
nombre d'entre eux aujourd'hui vous avez
près de 400000 logements aujourd'hui qui
sont habités par des personnes âgées ou
handicapées qui n'ont pas accès à leur
terrasse ou à leur balcon tout
simplement parce qu'il y a un seuil de
porte aujourd'hui on a quasiment 800000
immeubles en France pour lesquels le
haall d'entrée avec avec ascenseur n'est
pas accessible de la voirie parce qu' il
y a une ou deux ou trois marches à
l'entrée de l'immeuble chose que nous
connaissons tous et
euh depuis la je dirais la fondir de
produits artisanaux que nous faisons
actuellement aujourd'hui au de nos
ateliers ben on s'est aperçu qu'il y
avait une demande extrêmement forte pour
pouvoir répondre avec des produits sur
mesure que nous sommes les seuls à faire
aujourd'hui en France et en Europe sur
la base de de nos rampes en fibre de
verre d'ord donc l'idée elle est là
c'est de pouvoir en fait proposer à
toute personne à à mobilité réduite
d'avoir à domicile la même qualité de
vie qu'une personne valide et lui
permettre effectivement de d'entrer dans
son immeuble facilement et de et ben de
profiter les extérieurs de ces terrasses
ou de son de son balcon euh mais mais
cette croissance cette croissance là
très compliqué de le faire en en intern
et seul parce que on a subi très
durement le covid la crise
covid à la fois sur nos activités je
dirais régulière mais également sur les
activités de location destiné au
tourisme et év pour sortir voilà c'est
tourisme cettetielle évidemment pendant
2 ans et demi pratiquement était à zéro
effectivement pour nous donc tout nos
ressources ont été utilisées pour
pouvoir conserver nos équipes conserver
nos activités et cetera et là on a une
grosse vraiment une très grosse
opportunité pour la France et pour
l'Europe êt les seuls à faire ça oui voà
et donc bah il il faut qu'on trouve
effectivement des fonds pour pouvoir
lancer ce projet qui est à la fois de
réindustrialisation de croissance
industrielle et de digitalisation des
process alors là où c'est intéressant
c'est puis que vous dites bah va falloir
trouver des en effet de l'investissement
des des fonds et vous allez procéder à
une levée de fond participative et
inclusive euh c'est-à-dire que vous
allez pas faire ce qu'on dirait qu'on va
faire généralement c'est dire aller
chercher les banques quoi alors euh oui
pour alors première raison pour les
banques c'est que effectivement les tris
années que nous venons de passer ont été
compliqué c'est-à-dire que les banques
n'ont pas été les premiers financiers à
venir nous soutenir sur ce projet
euh d' d'une façon générale euh est-ce
que les banques font leur boulot ou pas
enfin vous avez l'impression
ve le secour-ce qu' qu'est-ce qu'on leur
demande ouais c'est euh mais c'est vrai
qu'aujourd'hui euh c'est quand même
compliqué hein c'est c'est pour obtenir
non des des fonds d'une banque ououi
alors d'abord en plus il coûte plus cher
ça c'est ça c'est clair et maintenant le
PGE a fait quand même en fait à à
comment dirais-je prê garantie hein ouai
excusez-moi le prê garanti par l'État
par l'État oui alors qui était après la
crise du covid enfin pendant la crise du
covid voà pendant la crise du covid qui
a permis c'était une une excellente
solution de toute façon qui a permis
vraiment de de maintenir un certain
nombre d'entreprises sauf que ça a
déstructuré quand même les les les les
comptes des entreprises euh avec parfois
des notes de Banque de France qui sont
qui ont été détérioré par rapport à ça
et donc aujourd'hui euh en fait ce qui
s'est passé c'est qu'on a prêté de
l'argent à des entreprises pour assurer
leur leur quotidien ouais et le jour où
ils ont besoin de l'argent pour se
développer bah il y en a plus forcément
c'est c'est déjà utilisé donc euh c'est
un vrai euh une vraie difficulté et
c'est vrai que certaines banques sont
pas toujours
hyper elles elles regardent les ratios
vraiment vraiment au cordau je reviens à
vous jean-pa mais oui je parlais à la
présidente de la CPM j'étais en train de
alors déjà je j'annonce mais Gill aussi
préside la commission entreprise en
difficulté à la CPME du département donc
c'est aussi l'idée c'est de trouver
d'autres solutions on le sait il y a
quelques difficultés après le covid pour
les entreprises c'est aussi que toutes
les aides s'appuie sur les fonds propres
les fonds propres se seront écroulés
donc c'est aussi compliqué d'aller
mobiliser de l'argent euh aujourd'hui
c'est vrai que les banques elles sont
beaucoup plus frileuse aussi parce que
il y a des PG qui ont pas été parfois
remboursés et donc ça peut créer une
petite angoisse que de suivre certains
dossiers et puis effectivement elle
regarde des ratios et et et quand on
regarde des ratios et des entreprises je
je pense que la plupart des start-ups
qui aujourd'hui explosent n'avaient pas
des super ratio démarrage donc c'est
vrai que c'est pas toujours évident il y
a quand même une une formation de base
ou ou voilà et peut-être un état
d'esprit différent à avoir et c'est vrai
que le fait de lever maintenant des
fonds en ligne comme le fait Axel c'est
une bonne solution un pour
mobiliser un autre public qui a envie de
s'investir non pas que mettre de
l'argent mais aussi s'investir dans un
projet dans un dans une histoire
embarqué dans une aventure voilà c'est
c'est c'est c'est une belle aventure
enfin donc voilà donc vous avez choisi
de pas aller voir les les les les
banques ENF vous avez choisi où ils ont
choisi enfin vous avez choisi tous les
deux qui
c'est pas choisi habuellement regarde
plus dans le rétroviseur effectivement
et les ratios que mais c'est parce
qu'ils sont formatés comme ça et que les
r sont comme ça
euh deuxème levier possible c'était les
fonds d'investissement mais là on est
trop petit et nous sommes une une
entreprise existance une PM existante on
n pas une start-up depuis 13 ans on
n'est plus une start-up quoi donc
effectivement le regard est
effectivement différent donc on est
aujourd'hui sur un double levier pour
cette pour cette accélération et cette
levée de fond le premier c'est euh
s'adressant à des business angel euh
donc des investisseurs privés y compris
régionaux et locaux pour nous
accompagner là-dessus et puis la
deuxième chose comme nous sommes déjà
dans notre activité on est déjà une
société impact et notre activité autour
du handicap et des seniors làdessus
l'idée c'était de c'est de pouvoir
proposer euh donc à des à des
particuliers
euh à des aidants à des clients à des
fournisseurs de pouvoir participer à
hauteur de de leur de leur moyen et ça
peut être quelques dizaines d'euros
voilà c'est enfin c'est déjà c'est déjà
en en place le al c'est lancé
l'opération est lancée maintenant depuis
le mois de depuis le mois de décembre
fin décembre voilà donc on est donc on
aller voir sur votre site aller voir sur
notre site directement où on on explique
un petit peu ces éléments là l'idée
c'est que toute personne tout
particulier concerné qui était un jour
ou l'autre concerné on a vendu plus de
20000 rampes d'accès handicapé depuis la
création de l'entreprise des
particuliers ou des commerçants c'est
leur dire ben soyez aussi acteurs
vous-même demain soit parce que vous
l'avez utilisé soit parce que peut-être
vous quelqu'un de vreentorage aura
besoin de ce type de de produit et
faisons évoluer ces éléments là ensemble
est-ce qu'il y a des aides aussi alors
plus institutionnel plus public je
pense peut-être com de Saint-Quentin
peut-être le département peut-être la
région oui il y a différentes
différentes aides qui existent à niau ça
depuis je dirais l'État la Région le
Département et même et même la zone que
ce soit des fonds de revitalisation que
ce soit des des projets type
accompagnement de la région type tpupou
pmup ou l'accompagnement de
l'industrialisation voire même en ce qui
nous concerne au travers de G DIRIS de
BP ou d'atou France pour pour
l'exportation des aides au développement
à l'exportation mais tout ça je dirais
doit rentrer dans un cadre global notre
première étape c'est effectivement lev
de fond de façon à pouvoir consolider ça
et ensuite en fonction de notre projet à
la fois industriel d'exportation de
pouvoir ensuite mobiliser des des
soutiens des régions pour il a les C
aussi non bah la C sert de relais en
fait est un relais relais de Région
Département par Rapp voilà notre
vocation étant sur le territoire à la
fois de développer l'industrialisation
parce que je n'ai pas dit c'est que ces
produits je dirais tous ces tous ces
outillage c'est une activité que nous
avons repris un fournisseur anglais que
nous avons rapatrié en France il y a 4
ans maintenant donc c'est c'est une
nouvelle industrialisation sur le
territoire de 51 ville mais c'est
également bah la création d'emploi et
notre objectif à 4 ans c'est d'augmenter
de 45 % notre notre masse salariale vous
disz vous êtes 18 dans cette entreise
donc c'est presque familial j'allais
dire euh comment comment ils réagissent
à cette croissance est-ce est-ce qu'ils
sont acteurs de de ça en disant on est
en train de vivre une époque formidable
ou est-ce que dis on est un peu
dépossédé de de notre non non pas du
tout dépossédé parce que j' dirais
l'idée il a double idée derrière
derrière ça est ce que j'aiexliquais à
l'ensemble du des équipes et qui sont
vraiment motivés derrière c'est que moi
j'étais seul au manette effectivement
depuis depuis maintenant 13 ans
euh je dirais un petit peu on évoquait
tout à l'heure au four moulin et sur
lesvier et avec avec une équipe qui
commence de plus en plus être être
responsabilisé mais c'est aussi
l'opportunité en particulier avec des
Business Angel qui souhaitent j' dirais
participer et s'investir à temps partiel
euh bah de de de pouvoir avoir des
nouvelles compétences et un nouveau
regard qui rentre dans l'entreprise et
qui n permettent également de je dirais
de d'accélérer et de trouver de voilà et
de trouver de ouais de développement de
développement Virg un mot justement sur
la levée de fond vous l'avez fait
beaucoup pour des start-ups he
euh vous vous adressez à qui dans ce cas
dans ce cas-là alors c'est c'est vrai
qu'il a raison Jean-Paul de dire que
c'est pas pareil quand une start-up ou
une entreprise qui est déjà plus
importante hein exactement ça dépend le
stade où on en est effectivement si on
est en amorçage ou si on est en
accélération les fonds mobilisables où
les réseaux sont pas les mêmes déjà et
puis ensuite il y a le choix de de lever
des fonds par des réseaux ou par des
business angel individuels c'est
vraiment une stratégie à mettre à j'ai
dire que d'ailleurs c'est le sujet un
peu qui qui relie toutes nos discussions
c'est la stratégie est hyper importante
c'estd à qui où est-ce que je vais
exactement parce que ça se construit
progressivement voilà souvent on se
jette à l'eau comme ça bah il faut de
l'argent il faut de l'argent et en fait
non euh il y a combien je dois lever
pour faire quoi quels sont mes objectifs
et comment je vais le faire quels sont
mes moyens à disposition ce qui me
manque et en fonction de ça on
construire une vraie stratégie bon
j'allais dire et ça c'est ma casquette
numérique que le digital encore une fois
dans ces momentsl est vraiment clé moi
j'ai levé des fonds aussi comme ça
c'estd que effectivement j'ai travaillé
mon personnal branding j'ai partagé mon
histoire j'ai partagé mon parcours mes
valeurs et puis je suis allé cibler les
gens qui m'intéressaient et ceux que je
voulais voir dans mon capital et j'ai
pas j'ai pas tapé
sur un malentenduel qui vient exactement
et donc c'est important d'avoir cette
stratégie de la réfléchir
stratégie alors on va aborder le dernier
volet de de cette émission c'est celui
de la la vente de l'entreprise avec vous
al
duen alors en cas donc maintenant je
sais comment on
dit en
cas vous avez eu plusieurs reprise de
enfin avant enc c'est ça oui j'ai je
suis tombé dans la franchise en étant
petit dire parce que j'ai commencé avec
Midas quand ils sont arrivés en France
d'accord et puis ensuite je suis passé
dans l'agencement avec une filiale de
enfin une franchise de l'industriel Kaz
sur l'enseigne les Ases du placard que
j'ai racheté avec quelques autres
franchisés et j'ai créé l'enseigne
Archea qui existe toujours qui a une
cinquantaine de de points de vente
aujourd'hui
il y a 17 ans j'ai revendu mon affaire
enfin mes parts et j'ai voulu créer une
entreprise tout seul puisqueavant on
était chez arquea plusieurs coggérants
et donc j'ai je me suis tourné vers la
restauration rapide de LC parce que en
2000 en 2008 c'était quasiment le
secteur qui avait le plus de d'espoir de
croissance donc j'ai créé Enka
euh à l'époque il y avait surtout McDo
et et puis la malbouffe et pas trop de
restauration rapide comme on a
aujourd'hui aujourd'hui il y a plur
d'offre donc on est habitué et pour oui
ça c'est la qualité c'est'est amélioré
mais à l'époque oui il y avait pas à
l'époque il y avait pas grand chose il y
avait pas grand chose et et pour me
différencier surtout sans être trop long
là-dessus mais j'ai voulu me démarquer
des États-Unis qui étaient synonyme de
malbouff aujourd'hui c'est peut-être
plus tout à fait le cas en me
rapprochant d'un pays nordique qui est
la Finlande et de m'appeler en cas pour
le jeun de mot voilà pour dire que c'est
de la bonne bouffe enfin la une offre en
tout cas elleci et et au bout de 17 ans
j'ai revendu mon entreprise donc j'ai
repris ce concept qui m'a donné vraiment
que du plaisir AC que des avantages et
aujourd'hui aujourd'hui à l'âge de 66
ans il faut bien que je pense
à à passer le flambau et ce qui
m'intéresse surtout c'est je pense que
c'est le cas de beaucoup de chefs
d'entreprise c'est que on s prend
toujours trop tard même si moi je m'y
étais pris il y a 4 5 ans mais vendre
une entreprise ça met facilement 12 24
et voir plus hein c'est c'est très très
long très long ouis ou et et le covid
comme je disis pas facilité les choses a
complètement stoppé les relations
puisqu'on se disait on va attendre la
sortie du covid cette sortie du covid a
mis très longtemps puisqu'on était plus
de 2 ans concerné donc ça a été
là-dessus un un arrêt total et
maintenant je reprends puisque on est
complètement en redémarrage sauf que
les habitudes des consommateurs ont
changé on était en zone purement
tercière donc j'ai décidé de me mettre
en zone de furfu de me développer sous
une forme plus coconing pour être ouvert
toute la journée au lieu d'être ouvert
que le midi aujourd'hui c'est un système
qui a beaucoup de difficultés que le
midi vous allez à la défense le vendredi
il y a personne hein vous pouvezer
tétravail et tout ça
oui bien sûr donc il faut se diversifier
et le modèle que j'ai conçu j'y crois
beaucoup avec une complémentarité de
l'offre en lançant le B2B c'est-à-dire
le un peu le l'événementiel mais dans
entre 5 et et et 20 personnes pas plus
hein on reste dans le nos clients queon
connaît bien mais pour lancer tout ça il
faut il faut remettre de
l'investissement financier et de
l'investissement humain et il faut que
j'ai un partenaire un repreneur qui
vienne reprendre le travail que j'ai
fait depuis quelques années pour ce
nouveau concept et et et moi qui puisse
prendre une place au soleil bien bien
mérité mais ce qui me ferait vraiment
mal au cœur c'est de perdre mon enseigne
et de pas pouvoir
trouver qu' qu'elle disparaisse avec
vous si je peux dire disparaiss qu'elle
vienne à mourir tout seul quoi et contre
comment on fait alors
voilà maintenant ça j'enis voilà je
voudrais bien prendre une retraite
méritée je vendre monentreprise comment
on fait on passe des annonces on
fait non les annonces c'est pas je c'est
pas le meilleur moyen mais on s'adresse
à à des banques d'affaires enfin ou à
des personnes qui qui sont spécialisé
làdedans qui vont voir des cibles et qui
mettre en en relation des éventuells
éventuelurs d'accord voilà mais bon
toujours pareil la période covid
aujourd'hui elle est pas non plus très
les banques sont pas non plus très faste
à à suivre les projets comme ça parce
que quand vous allez un repreneur va
voir une banque qui va lui présenter les
les bilans de l'entreprise les bilans de
l'entreprise en période covid sont pas
bons et donc pour lever de l'argent
notamment auprès des organismes
bancaires c'est quasiment mission
impossible donc l'entreprise est
vendable au niveau de de son
projet commercial parce que la franchise
ça monte très vite hein quand on on peut
on a un un produit banquebol on peut y
aller ça ça se démultiplie très vite
c'est une bonne une bonne formule mais
mais aujourd'hui c'est difficilement
finançable parce que tous les banques et
les investisseurs vont regarder le côté
financier passé le côté bilan et le côté
bilan il faut encore attendre 2 ans pour
bien s pour que ça se
stabiliseou si je peux me permettre
j'ajouterai aussi et je pense que Gilles
ça rejoint un peu ce que tu disais au
démarrage mais il y a aussi le capital
immatériel qu'on valorise pas toujours
dans dans un bilan et qui se voit pas
toujours la marque la entation du site
la notoriété sur les réseaux alors
évidemment mais il travail du chef
d'entreprise il y a le travail et c'est
vrai que le plus dur moiême pour avoir
vécu C période mais c'est vrai que le
plus dur c'est aussi de prendre du recul
pour savoir ce qu'il y a de la valeur
aussi aux yeux d'un potentiel
investisseur repreneur et que parfois C
des de de de gens comme comme comme toi
effectivement ça permet d'être d'avoir
une prise de recul qui permet de se dire
ah d'accord ça je l'ai pas valorisé dans
mon bilan pendant des années et
finalement parce qu' une époque c'est
vrai qu'on avait cette habitude de
valoriser locau les machines et CETA et
c'était quelque chose de très rationnel
sur ce qui était palpable ou matériel et
effectivement et quand je discute aussi
maintenant avec les commissaire au
comptte et cetera enfin on a ce retour
là de ce fameux capital immatériel qu'on
a du mal à je sais pas si tu veux dire
un mot dessus mais fa juste
effectivement un repreneur va être
intéressé par le le le projet enfin
l'avenir c'est ça donc tu tu as préparé
déjà vous avez préparé un plan d'avenir
qui peut qui peut intéresser bien
évidemment un repreneur et du coup il
pourra il pourra se payer en quelque
sorte sur ce sur ce projet de
déveloement donc a tout y a tout
matériel les développement c'est pas que
le passé ouais exactement on on parle
des fois aussi par ça sur le passé mais
le développement et la valeur d'
entreprise c'est aussi son avenir quoi
c'est c'est ça qu'il faut faut Dee façon
pour conclure parce que malheureusement
le on a fini le temps qui nous était
imparti
justement àin duant son entreprise
est-ce que vous avez l'impression une
époque Mo j'ai cette impression là mais
je je ù justement le désir
d'entreprendre le désir de d'être
responsable soitmême de de ce qu'on fait
chef d'entreprise et plus fort
aujourd'hui qu'il l'a été par le passé
en France ah c'est sûr la création
d'entreprise d'ailleurs est assez forte
et on le voit et puis en fait je pense
aussi que le télétravail le covid a fait
une prise de conscience à certains de se
dire bah finalement si je travaille tout
seul dans mon coin je suis peut-être
capable aussi de créer mon activité
alors après il faut aussi distinguer la
création d'entreprise au sens projet
d'équipe avec un objectif et puis la
création de son propre emploi
indépendant qui est quand même une
distinction importante parce que être
auto-entrepreneur et se dire je je veux
vendre je veux vendre moi-même et mes
prestations c'est une chose créer une
entreise tout la même chose que de créer
une entreprise les enux sont les mê
son mê il y en a qui sera presque plus
parfois du salariat d'ailleurs que de la
création d'entreprise et et finalement
qui une forme de travail de l'évolution
de la société actuelle mais mais donc
effectivement la création d'entreprise
aujourd'hui elle de création
d'entreprise j'ai l'impression ou et je
pense queelle va attirer de plus en plus
quand même parce que on a on a soif de
développer son projet et qu'aujourd'hui
quand même elle n'a jamais été aussi
facile on crée une entreprise en ligne
rapidement à l'époque de nos de de mes
parent en tout cas il fallait mettre un
gros capital il y avait des barrières à
l'entrée il y avait des normes et cetera
qui étaient très poussé aujourd'hui on
peut quand même se lancer plus
facilement j'ai pas dit que la réussite
est plus
simpmocratis si on
pourit il y a un écosystème aujourd'hui
qui est ultra favorable aujourd'hui en
France il y a y a un chiffre là qui est
tombé il y a pas longtemps il y a 50 %
des des créateurs d'entreprise alors
dedans il y a tout le monde qui sont
payés par po emploi aujourd'hui donc au
moins l'écosystème de P emploi favor
c'est pas mal un bel investisseur c'est
plutôt démage quoi
c'est non mais c'est c'est c'est c'est
c'est plutôt une bonne nouvelle oui
ouais ouais ouais tout à fait merci
beaucoup merci beaucoup à tous les cinq
et et alors je sais pas ce qu'il vous
vous souhaitez mais enfin bravo déjà euh
pour ce que vous avez accompli et puis
voilà je sais pas si on dit bonne chance
ou on peut dire ça on dit merde on peut
aussi on dit rendez-vous sur
axel.fr rendez-vous sur
de
asondos merci à tous
etid oubl quand même merci à tous les
sacs
[Musique]
merci